this portuguese
presidency comes at a very crucial point
in time
where we are battling this pandemic and
indeed on one hand we see the vaccine
roll out
and this is the light at the end of the
tunnel we know that
but we also know that the months and
weeks ahead will be hard for citizens
they'll be
hard for businesses because we all are
aware of the fact that we still need
lockdowns across europe and this comes
of course at a high
price it is now very reassuring that
we succeed to put in place our vaccine
strategies greatly and swiftly
but also to have next generation eu
because we know the longer the crisis
lasts
the more important it is that we come
with strong investment
that at the same time modernizes into
the european green deal
the digitalization and of course
reinforces
the appropriate social safeguards that
are necessary
it is necessary now that we have a swift
ratification process
for next generation eu in the respective
member states because we do need now
the economic recovery